an einem nebligen morgen zeigen sich die
stars des berliner zoos in ihrem gehege
und lancia spitznamen bit und paule sie
sind die ersten pandas die jemals in
deutschland geboren wurden
tierpfleger corvin schmohl kümmert sich
seit ihrer geburt um die beiden und hat
ihre entwicklung in den vergangenen zehn
monaten aufmerksam verfolgt
wir haben hier sehr viele lustige
situation mit den beiden kleinen gerade
momentan ist das hauptthema die beiden
dort oben wieder runter zu bekommen weil
wenn die da am schlafen sind ist es
relativ schwierig da sie noch nicht so
gut auf ihren namen hören müssen wir
halt probieren die so ein bisschen zu
motivieren und zu ein bisschen runter zu
locken das sieht von außen immer sehr
unterhaltsam aus denn die sind schon
sehr stur
pitt und paule wurden im august 2009 10
geboren nach etwa drei wochen bekamen
sie die typische schwarz weiße färbung
besonders viele artgenossen haben sie
nicht weniger als 2000 große anders
leben schätzungsweise in freier wildbahn
etwa 600 gibt es in gefangenschaft
die nachzucht der einzelgänger ist eine
komplizierte angelegenheit
die zucht beim panda ist nicht so
einfach da gibt es eine kleine
besonderheit nämlich die weiblichen
tiere sind im ganzen jahr nur ungefähr
drei tage aufnahmefähig und das ist
natürlich sehr sehr kurzer und
begrenzter zeitraum den wir natürlich
zum einen perfekt passen müssen und da
darf einfach nichts schiefgehen weil
ansonsten müssen wir halt wieder ein
jahr warten bevor wir die nächsten
anlauf starten können
die pandas sind eine leihgabe aus china
mutter und vater george in kamen im juli
2017 nach berlin
schon zwei jahre später klappte es mit
dem nachwuchs pandabären verbringen den
größten teil des tages mit strafen
hoffen schmohl präpariert ein stück
stoff mit eukalyptus umbau zum spielen
zu animieren
das scheint zu klappen zumindest für
fünf minuten dann heisst es
pause der bärenhunger ist trotzdem groß
für die pandas importiert der berliner
zu tonnenweise bambus aus frankreich und
den niederlanden
wir brauchen hier sehr große mengen an
bambus denn das männchen bekommt täglich
schon um die 40 kilo bambus und die
mengen auch momentan so 45 kilo und das
sind natürlich enorme mengen die da über
eine woche zusammenkommen und die beiden
kleinen fragen sich auch so langsam an
dafür zu interessieren also sie knabbern
schon mal so ein bisschen auf den
blättern drauf rum
bei den besuchern des berliner zoos
sorgen die pandas für begeisterung
auch wenn es für peter und paul bald
schon wieder zeit für ein nickerchen ist